muy bien se nos pide multiplicar 5
sextos por 2 tercios y tenemos que
simplificar la respuesta entonces
queremos multiplicar 5 sextos por dos
tercios
multiplicar es un proceso muy directo en
el numerador va el producto de los
numeradores y en el denominador va el
producto de los denominadores entonces
en este caso tendríamos 5 por 2 en el
numerador y 6 por 3 en el denominador y
ahora para obtener el resultado
simplemente tenemos que multiplicar
5 x 2 es 10
y 6 por 3 10 18 y nos queda 10 18 a vos
que es el resultado de 5 sextos de dos
tercios o dos tercios de 5 sextos
depende de cómo lo quieras ver seguro ya
te diste cuenta que tanto el numerador
como el denominador tienen un factor
común los dos se pueden dividir entre
dos entonces para simplificar la
respuesta 10 lo podemos dividir entre 2
y 18 también lo podemos dividir entre
210 entre 25 y 18 entre 239 así que
cinco novenos es la respuesta
simplificada a nuestro producto pero
pudimos haber simplificado desde antes
por ejemplo desde aquí porque en el
numerador tenemos un producto que tiene
un 2 y en el denominador tenemos un
número que tiene a 2 como factor pudimos
haber dividido el 2 entre 2
y nos da 1 y el 6 entre 2 y nos queda 3
así que esto es igual
a 5 x 15 en el numerador y en el
denominador 3 por 3 que es 9 y nos salió
5 novenos que es lo que ya habíamos
obtenido pero qué creés todavía
podríamos haber simplificado desde antes
es decir desde aquí ya observando bien
aquí tenemos el 2 y aquí tenemos el 6
que tiene a 2 como factor entonces
dividimos 2 entre 2 nos da 1 y 6 entre 2
que nos da 3
y esto es lo mismo que 5 por 15 entre 3
por 3 que es 9 y volvimos a obtener 5
novenos entonces ya sea que simplifica
es al final o si te das cuenta que puede
simplificar desde antes o más desde
antes esta es la forma de computar una
multiplicación de fracciones